ich wollte wieder unterwegs und ich hab
ein video gesehen habe dass wir auf
jeden fall reagieren müssen leute trends
platz eins jong il hat eine haustür
hochgeladen ich zeige euch mein
komplettes haus und wir können natürlich
wegschauen leute einerseits weil ich
persönlich immer sehr sympathisch fanden
privat getroffen habe und andererseits
das auch ziemlich krank aussieht alter
wir fangen jetzt an halo ein klein wenig
freunde ihr habt euch alle so sehr
gewünscht und deswegen würde ich sagen
ich will einfach jetzt mal auf dem
größten traum ich zeig euch jetzt mein
gesamtes der krankheit für diese
eingangsbereich ist schon ganz ganz ganz
wilder flex leute eine sache wieder
vorneweg sagen bevor wir weiter ins
detail eingehen persönlich habe ich auch
irgendwie ein bisschen engere verbindung
zu zögerlich weil wir groß miteinander
zeit verbringen oder so sondern weil
meine kleine schwester einfach früher
eine hardcore fan von ihm war wirklich
hardcore dich deswegen gezwungen war
aber ich glaube schon zwei gelegenheiten
einfach für meine schwestern bilden mit
ihm zu machen schauen finden wir ja wenn
ich euch ja und das am rande warum
dieses video doppelte und jetzt wirklich
so süß
er ist wirklich suite das ist auch eine
sache warum ich immer sehr sympathisch
fand weil der so sehr noch purist ich
meine also das ist ja sehr sehr
ungefiltert ist an der art und weise wie
er auf you tube redet ich weiß auch
nicht woran das liegt aber ich finde
sowas finde ich immer so todes
sympathisch wenn man wirklich leute
sieht wie die irgendwie reden oder sich
verhalten also man sieht okay das ist
jetzt wirklich ungefähr verstellt sich
niemand der das beste
das ist hat sich relativ sich leute also
direkt am anfang wirklich verbrecher ihr
alter also ich hab schon einige häuser
gesehen leute auch wirklich schon häuser
toren von den kranken will nirgendwo in
los angeles aber das hier sieht man
wirklich ganz ganz selten dass ein haus
eine eingangstür hat sogar mit türgriff
luxus dass das ist das ist wirklich also
man muss wirklich sagen also man sieht
es sofort wird es bestimmt auch sofort
gesehen wenn man sich dieses haus
anschaut weiß man das ist der person die
da drin lebt gut geht und dass gar nicht
alle wie gesagt von ganzem herzen ich
habe ihn persönlich leider noch nicht
gross kennengelernt oder so aber das war
sich soweit gesehen wie zwei drei mal
getroffen hat plus dazu wir eben auf
youtube ist wie er sich so gibt egal
gültig ist ihm wirklich gibt andere
heute wo man vielleicht auge machen
würde aber eben auf gar keinen fall
das ist das wirklich geil gebt euch das
geht euch dass dieses dieses offene
esszimmer oder was das da ist mit diesem
mit dem tisch da und dann geht's ab 1 80
meter nach oben
ja das ist also wirklich props props
gibt mit sicherheit viele leute in
deutschland die calado und mitte 40 sind
oder so gerne so ein haus hätten also da
muss aus eigener kraft
der kirche timmelsjoch für den schrank
mega sache das hat wirklich jeder
youtuber sein hauseigenes bin gibt wer
bist du nach hause einfach so eine
einbauschrank turbo s ist helfer so
komplettes verlieren inso nicht jetzt
wirklich turbo relevanten details das
wirklichkeit leute es ist wirklich aber
das kriegt mich auch gerade
es gibt in deutschland einfach so ein
paar leute die einfach richtig geile
sachen machen die selbstständig sind ihr
auf youtube oder auch in anderen
branchen ich keine zeit aber nur youtube
geilen stuff machen leute und ich finde
es richtig geil dass jemand einfach so
was cooles macht und damit sich so etwas
leisten kann also muss man sich mal vor
augen ich weiß nicht genau was es beim
losging oder so aber kann ich sag es mal
vor sechs oder sieben jahren ging es los
bei ihm wie videos und heute hat er
einfach ein haus ein haus damit
finanziert das ja im internet videos
macht das ist auf einmal leute das ist
richtig wieder richtig bin immer auch
dahinter die wollte man auf
unterbrechungen geschlossen
es ist ein eigener ein eigener ansatz
eine eigene herangehensweise an häuser
anderer zeigen die gesagt ihre
einbauschränke ihre autos ihre kassen
garagen pool spot etwa so ist so kann
man hier das ist voll eklig
so schaut bitte einmal auf dieses
holzbrett dass schimmel gerade irgendwas
krank das ernst
so was ich will dir das hier oben das
wird er wahrscheinlich noch zeigen
diesen leichten glas also dass jetzt
wieder wissen weiter groß wahrscheinlich
ist dass hier oben einfach so eine
galerie so dass man im ersten stock der
ja das ist einfach geil ein gericht
kommt die studie auch richtig geil
wahrscheinlich ist es da oben so eine
galerie wo man quasi im ersten stock
offen runter ins esszimmer gucken kann
und da kann man quasi wenn man im ersten
stock ist irgendwie theoretisch etwas
runter werfen oder bei kann es hoch
werfen oder so leute dass das ist für
mich wirklich persönlich gold wenn ich
eines tages meine familie habe will ich
in einem haus leben wo alles so offen
ist und man sich einfach von jedem von
überall aus kann dann jeder jeden
abwerfen
sowas hier ein schmeißen sondern
bewerten ist von da oben
sagt doch sagt doch da malaga geil das
geil digger auch hier so die decken die
decken sport zu lichter in der decke
regal ist das wirklich wirklich also die
weiß natürlich auch immer des films und
die kamera ist also wahrscheinlich noch
ein color grading doch was auch immer
aber das ist wirklich ein geiles haus
weiter so wie wir sind hier in meinen
grunzen
da kann ich eigentlich schon fernseher
hirschau thema trash-tv hier sind nicht
immer auf der couch und da ist ja geil
geil es wirklichkeit also auch so dieser
kamine auf der ecke rega also das haus
ist wahrscheinlich recht also man sieht
es auf den ersten blick wahrscheinlich
relativ neu gebaut oder gekauft weiß
auch nicht also ich kann noch nicht
lange stehen so wie das aussieht der
kamine auf der ecke das ist einfach geil
so das ist ein stil sondern
architekturstil was jetzt nicht ob das
jetzt ob das jetzt das was man bauhaus-
nennt sein aber das ist schon richtig
richtig geile also sehr gerade form kann
man ecken heute jack marshall wirklich
schmeckt
hier seien per post mein gott es hat
alles mit diesem jahr nähe ist von
letzten jahr noch in diesem jahr gibt es
keine fanpost ja was haben alle ist görg
hatte einfach im postkeller das wird
leider kann man hier also auf dieses
niveau die kartons darunter
wahrscheinlich welche umzug sachen oder
so aber geht das ja nicht nur das team
richtig geil talk talk talk haus wohnt
er hat auch noch eine geschätzte
dreiviertel tonne an fanpost und im
keller vor rief er ich glaube ja
wirklich geisteskranke fans safe als
nicht dass sie durch die wird sind
sondern schaden wenn wir da so das nicht
aber ich glaube des fells und richtiger
hardcore fans sie lieben ihn okay sauna
läuft das gesetz war am rand der sonne
das ist auch schon das ist ein guter
flex muss ich sagen wenn man das sauna
im eigenen haus hat das ist der
zeitpunkt wo man wirklich so ritsch
ratsch es irgendwann also schmeckt
ich muss auch mal in wissentlich wie
sehr mir das weh tut dass hier zu sehen
die leute nicht weil er etwas falsch
gemacht hat aber mir fehlen
fitnessstudios so geisteskrank wirklich
so sogar ist es gar nicht trainiert und
die ganze zeit draußen viele von euch
wird ausprobieren ich habe einfach nicht
mehr so eine hantelbank zu hause was bin
ich für penner halter ich trainiere
einfach auf dem spielplatz was los da
bin ich achter so ok ok ok also des
hauses gemietet nicht gekauft davon
abgesehen muss man ihm an der stelle
muss man wirklich mit gefühl haben mit
ihnen das auch nicht leicht im mietshaus
denkt euch so ein geiles haus der feier
ich finde ich cool wie ich einziehen
dann ist ein von der sauna drin obwohl
er gar nicht sagt habe davon waren sie
doch recht gut aus okay es gibt ja
gesagt haben aber geile die steine hier
sind richtig neu ist dieses holz geil
alles schön modern
egal ob krank dass auch ein kranker
sechs leute dass das ist auch dass es
auch unter youtube.de flex kann sich am
rande mal zählen oder in seinem eigenen
haus wirklich ein studio zu haben die
meisten leute mal war so wie ich aber
jetzt schreibt irgendwo wohnzimmer
arbeitszimmer was auch immer nehmen da
ihre videos auch wenn man ein eigenes
studio im wohnzimmer hat also du baust
quasi würden sie denn dein wohnzimmer
deine couch oder nimmst du nochmal
anderen raum und baust da noch einmal
ein anderes wohnzimmer einfach rein nur
um da videos zu drehen
das ist schon das ist schon geil das ist
wirklich geil zum videos machen muss ich
sagen
[Musik]
da diese durch der gigantischen kran
kann kann kein land egal das ist das ist
geil wieder selber so leicht so
sandfarbene steine hier fed aber diese
dusche flash wirklich am meisten lenker
des anderen tag würden manche leute
würden drin wohnen auf der fläche also
props wirklich da ist das große bahn
weist auch schon der letzte raum in
seiner haustür ich muss wirklich sagen
der baba haus job gar nicht mehr
wirklich gratuliere dazu auch wenn sie
nur gemietet ist wahrscheinlich nicht
ewig dabei musste er genießt es sehr
sehr sehr geil und ihr habt keine ahnung
tag in einer dusche bei autos oder sowie
passend auf jeden fall rein steckt hier
natürlich vorgeschlagenes video aber
nicht um einen kanal damit ich eines
tages vielleicht auch mal in so einem
haus leben kann wer eigentlich an
zitierte daraus macht's gut